All right, let's get into audience questions
for the week, very relevant and prescient
questions today.
The first is, hey, David could so call the
rhino's be better allies for removing Trump
than the never Biden people in November of
twenty twenty rhinos are Republicans in name
only.
OK.
I think that thinking that is sort of defeatist.
And I'm going to tell you why.
There is no doubt that there is a Republican
movement that hates Trump and wants to remove
him.
This includes people like George Conway, the
husband of Trump adviser Kellyanne Conway.
This includes people like, you know, there's
this Steve Schmidt is an adviser and Rick
Wilson, who I've interviewed on the show.
These are Republican strategist types who
don't like Trump and want to see him removed.
Now, the question about allies could be interpreted
two ways.
Number one is just like in the sheer numbers
of it, do I think there will be more Republicans
who abandoned Trump and vote Biden than the
number of never Biden people who would normally
be Democratic voters, but are going to either
not vote or vote third party or vote for Donald
Trump?
I think the answer is no.
I mean, listen, every every election there
is abandonment.
If you look at 2008, there were a bunch of
people who voted for Hillary in the Democratic
primary and then voted for John McCain in
2016.
You saw some Bernie primary voters who abandoned
Hillary, who abandoned the party, so to speak,
and voted for Trump.
It was actually a smaller number than the
number that did the abandonment in 2008 and
went to McCain.
Every election you have that I don't think
the number is actually going to be that big.
And I know that the never Biden movement is
very, very loud online.
But you have to understand that there's a
lot of things that are very, very loud online.
And it turns out that they don't really reflect
reality as closely as we might imagine or
we might even hope the Bernie run is an example
of that.
So much online activity.
And then Bernie lost three consecutive Super
Tuesdays, only the last of.
By that I mean the three Tuesdays in March
that have a bunch of elections.
Only the last one was even moderately affected
by the Corona virus.
And there's no particular reason to believe
that that actually hurt Bernie more than it
hurt Biden.
So I don't actually think that the never Biden
movement is going to be what prevents Biden
from winning.
I think that there is no question, though,
that we should welcome Republicans who are
not going to vote Trump once Trump's out,
whoever the next president is, either Biden
in in winning in November or some other Democrat
winning four years from now.
At some point, those Republicans are going
to be back to disagreeing with us on most
policy.
And that's it.
So the idea of them being allies, anybody
who doesn't vote for Trump votes for Biden.
Right.
Any one of those votes helps remove Donald
Trump and we'll take it.
And we love it.
And it's all fantastic.
The more people that realize that this guy
is a lethal menace, the better and more efficiently
that we can remove him.
But I worry about the hostility of saying,
man, some of these Republicans are better
allies than the never Biden people.
We it's not one or the other.
We need everybody.
And there are reasons why people might be
Republicans and not want Trump.
That would be completely unaligned with our
values.
We might be not really a small government
conservative.
They hate that he did the stimulus.
Like there's people that are mad at Trump
on the right because he did the corona virus
stimulus coronavirus stimulus wasn't big enough.
I mean, OK, if they don't want to vote Trump
in November because of it and they're going
to help Biden win by one vote each.
I'll take it.
But the reason they disagree with Trump might
be completely not in line with our values.
So everybody's an ally who helps remove Trump.
But the idea that we want to start shaming
never Biden people by saying these rhinos
are even better allies for us.
I don't think it's a good idea.
I don't think it's pragmatic.
I don't think it's based
on
the facts either.